Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, also known as
Rawkode. This is Rawkode Live. I just like
seeing Rawkode as many times as I can
in the first ten seconds.
And I also hate myself a little bit
for it. Now moving on with today's session,
we are taking a look at a CNCF
sandbox project.
This is SchemaHero.
SchemaHero is going to make all of our
database migration lives a whole of lot easier.
And I am not gonna show you. Well,
I am kind of, but we are joined
by a wonderful guest, maintainer of the project,
Mark Campbell,
who is gonna keep us up to date
on all things SchemaHero.
How's it going, Mark? How are you? It's
great. Thanks for having me. Excited to be
here.
Yeah. Yeah. It's awesome.
I've been looking at this project for a
while, and I'm I'm really keen to kinda
play with it and just see how it
can simplify my life a little bit.
I mean, I I think I've had the
worst luck with databases throughout my entire career.
So I'm really looking for, like, the
secret weapon to making my life a little
bit easier. Is is that is that what
we're gonna get today?
Hopefully.
That was like our goal. I think, you
know, I don't know. Maybe maybe you've had
the second worst luck with databases. We had
so such bad luck, we created a whole
project around it to make it easier. Yeah.
Okay.
Before we get back into SchemaHero and and
start showing people what this thing can do,
can you tell us a little bit about
yourself, please?
Yeah. Sure.
So, yeah, I'm Mark Campbell. I'm cofounder and
CTO of Replicated.
At Replicated, we're helping software vendors ship enterprise
versions behind the firewall installable products, versions of
their product to their enterprise customers.
As we focus on Kubernetes, so you take
a Kubernetes app, package it up as a
Kubernetes app, a Helm chart, whatever, in replicated,
can help you deliver that to air gapped
environments and complex environments.
And as part of that,
we
ran into a lot of different problems that
you don't run into when you deliver first
party software when you're trying to either deliver
third party software or consume third party software.
Database migrations were part of it. We created
SchemaHero and, you know, put it in the
CNCF sandbox and, like, excited to dig into
it a little bit more today. Yeah. It's
a bold name. Right? SchemaHero.
Like, I'm expecting some really big things from
this.
Yeah. Let's it'll deliver.
Could maybe we could talk about a little
bit of the the history of the project.
You know, you said you've I said I
have the worst luck. You said, no. You
probably have the worst luck as you build
a project. Like, why are database migrations so
difficult to get right?
Yeah. So, you know, we started off really
focused on the schema part of database migrations.
You know, we
we're using Goose
to run them. If you're familiar, it's like,
you know, writing Go code, and so we
would write SQL migrations often using Go.
And it generally worked pretty well,
but it was, like, imperative
where we would say, I want you to
go you know, you'd you'd write a SQL
migration that said go add a column, drop
a column, map, create a table.
And the challenge that we really had was,
like, kinda came around to you have to
be, like, really, really confident in the current
state of that database schema before you can
apply changes to it,
which generally sounds, you know, like an okay
thing. Right? Like, have my database. I can
go look at the schema, the state of
it, and then decide, okay. I wanna, like
here's the commands that I need to do
to alter it to what I want.
The problem is, like, in a you know,
when you're running a lot of migrations,
sequencing
becomes difficult. You might have three migrations pending,
and you each of them work against the
current state of the database. But when you
apply one, like, the second and the third
one are no longer valid, and it may
actually have, like, adverse side effects in kind
of, like, like, result in, like, a like,
dropping some data a a column or doing
something that you didn't expect.
And then for us, you know, again, since
we're delivering software into third party,
you know, enterprise customer controlled environments,
we have, like,
very little ability to guarantee the current state
of the database. And so all we wanted
to say is, you know, here's the state
that I want the database to be at,
kinda like Kubernetes. Right? It's very declarative.
SchemaHero
is, and we can just say, like, I
don't care what the state of the database
is right now. Here's the state that I
want the database at. Like, do whatever is
necessary to move it from a to b.
Yeah. I think that's one of the things
that got me really excited about it when
I was looking at the documentation.
Like, you know, I'll talk my database history
is starting off twenty five years ago, hand
rolled SQL that was deployed whenever we shut
the application
with probably
many more manual changes,
which I think it's just the way things
were back then. At least I don't think
I was doing anything too bad.
But then came along ORMs and they give
us this ability to kind of model our
code, our database as code, then it would
generate the migrations for us. And then those
would run on deploy.
And that worked really well, but then you
run into problems with rollbacks, whereas I I
think rollbacks are still always a problem. Right?
Like, probably just shouldn't rollback. I'll get your
thoughts on that if you want to share.
But
it's it's nice to see that go back
to what I was trying to make a
point of. I was at the SchemaHero documentation,
there were no SQL statements.
It was, like you said, a declarative, here's
what my database has to look like. Here
are the fields that I want. Here are
the types that they have, and I don't
need to worry about anything else. Like, that's
a pretty cool feature.
And
Yeah. Like, I mean, if you're used to,
you know, Rails or Django, you know, like
you mentioned ORMs and, like like, that pattern
was really, really good. Right? You don't have
like, it came with challenges around rollbacks and
a few different things, but but these challenges
are gonna exist. It's a complex subject. You
know? The the challenge really, though, was
Django or Rails, like, the migrations are pretty
tightly coupled into the ecosystem and the language
and the framework that you're actually using to,
like, to build stuff. And
not all languages, not all ecosystems have that.
Go has Go ORM. It's generally more around,
you know, not writing SQL statements at runtime,
but, like, that that that that functionality just
should exist, and it should be decoupled from
like, we thought, that functionality should exist and
be decoupled from the actual, like, language and
framework that you're using and actually push down
to the platform layer to be responsible for
it, kinda like what Kubernetes has done.
Yeah. I I I kinda wanna highlight one
distinction to make sure I have my own
mental models that kind of makes sense for
it. So for everyone who's not familiar how
the ORM migration stuff worked, when I generated
the SQL, every migration got an ID, that
was usually stored in the database to see
that migration had run. So typically, that migration
would never run again. And if you make
manual changes, any subsequent migrations that have to
run
wouldn't be aware of those changes and that
would break and then you just get paged
and then you're in a whole lot of
heart a few days while you work out
why there was a manual change in the
database.
What I got there
from looking at the documentation and and even
just talking to you now, it sounds like
SchemaHero
doesn't have any stored state. It's it's looking
at the database as it runs to work
out if there have been manual changes, would
it then
fix that for me? Is that Yeah.
Like, so, you know, like, we build that
in as, like, drift detection, right, as the
feature is what we're calling it.
And then exactly,
like it doesn't if you've
deployed and said, here's the state that I
want this table to be at, and then
somebody's gone and, you know, manually changed the
column type. And then the next time you
try to deploy that table, it's gonna detect
that and it's gonna say, that table, like
like, my job isn't to add this column
to the table or my job isn't to
add this foreign key. My job is to
make the actual table in, you know, Postgres
or Cassandra or Cockroach, whatever that is, match
the desired state that's defined in this YAML
file. And so it it ends up doing,
like, drift detection and bringing it back to
the desired state as needed.
Awesome. Well, it sounds exciting. I think we
should just dive right in. What what do
you think? Let's do it. Let's do it.
All right. Let's start off with what
I've done in advance. And the answer is
standard,
almost nothing. So we do have a Kubernetes
cluster.
This is running on Civo as KCS
running Kubernetes 120.
I
have no SchemaHero installed, but I did go
ahead and deploy Postgres
and MariaDB because I'm assuming we'll be working
with both of those today. These are empty,
they have no configuration, they have no data,
nothing like that. So we're starting from almost
zero
and I have the SchemaHero website here
and my expert. So I feel that we
have everything that we need to be successful
now. No pressure.
No pressure.
It's funny. It's like when I when people
join me on this show, the thing they're
not worried about is, like, their own confidence
or their knowledge. It's always the, oh, I
really hope our docs are up to date.
Oh, yeah. I hope they are. Documentation is
always just one of those really challenging things.
So yeah. Alright. Let's click on get started.
So I'm assuming the first thing we need
to do is just get this thing installed.
Yeah.
So I see we have two choices. Yeah.
Go for it. I was just gonna tell
you, there's there's two choices here. This is
like the the documentation on how to install
SchemaHero.
On the top nav bar, there's also a
tutorial. Like, whatever way you want to go
with, like, we like, it's under Learn SchemaHero,
one tab to the left.
Whichever path you want to take, one just
like this path still leaves you with SchemaHero
installed. It's a little bit more like, you
know, walk you through every single thing. Well,
yeah, I probably need all the help I
can get. So let's use the the start
of this tutorial because it says new to
SchemaHero and I I certainly am.
Alright. So we're getting some introduction.
It's even given us a little basic database
that we can design, so reservations,
schedules, and airports.
And I'm sure someone has spent a lot
of time putting this all together, but I'm
gonna skip onto the install step of the
Yeah. Let's do it.
Alright. So
it says so do we need something local
and something on the server? I see that
this is installing a a plugin. Do you
wanna kinda just break that down for us?
Yeah. So SchemaHero
is a it's
packaged the way I think that we're going
to go through it today, it's packaged as
a Kubernetes operator. It doesn't actually have to
run-in Kubernetes. It's just a CLI command, and
you can run it completely outside of Kubernetes
as long as it can talk to the
database. But, like, we're gonna go through it,
and we think the primary and kind of
the best use case is really, like, running
it as a Kubernetes operator.
So
we have a Helm chart. We have other,
like, you know, community supported ways to install
it. The preferred way for us is to
grab our kubectl plug in using Crew that
we publish called SchemaHero,
if you have Crew installed. If not, we
can get that too.
The ability is that will actually manage installing
the operator for you and also
kinda give you control SchemaHero
CLI commands so that you can interact exactly
with, you know, like, the SchemaHero extension inside
the cluster.
I normally have Crew installed, but I did
switch to my m one Mac recently. So
we'll need to
quickly grab this.
Looks fun.
Yeah. Am I supposed to trust us?
Seven seven lines of
of shell scripting here. Let's do it.
I'm looking for the safe option.
Yeah.
Alright. Let's do that. Although Homebrew can't be
notoriously slow, but, hopefully, it's not too bad.
I do love that they store all the
binaries and get help container registry now is
OCA artifacts. It's really clever.
Yeah.
There we go.
Great.
Alright. So installed.
So that just installed the the client side
portion, obviously. That hasn't, like, talked talked talked
to the cluster at all.
Yeah. It's now telling me to run the
kubectl SchemaHero install. So I'm assuming this is
what's gonna do. Go ahead and install the
operator to our cluster?
Exactly.
I just
I think you when you install brew, you
have to, like, add some path to the
shell in order to do it.
I've never Am I making this more difficult
for myself? Is that what you're saying?
I mean, when you go so, like, if
you maybe? Yeah. Exactly. Like, this this binary
exists somewhere now. Right? Like, I don't know
where it is on your path.
Neither do I. That's that's
great. Okay. Let's see. Do we have a
crude directory? We do. And we got a
Ben. So let's there we go. So we
are gonna do export
path.
Accru bin.
And then we're gonna run that again.
That looks better.
That's pretty fast.
Does it get a sort of namespace? It
does. Okay. It does. Yeah.
So I wanna elaborate on something that you
said there then. So let's close that. You
said that SchemaHero doesn't have to run-in cluster.
So with the use case
in fact, you said I could also just
run
cube control schema.
It's got a whole bunch of things on
it?
Exactly. Yeah. Like, you can you know, we'll
dive into it here. And so, like, in
in kinda getting into how SchemaHero works, but,
like, you can see there's a couple commands
there, plan and apply. Those are probably the
big important ones.
And so you can say, here's a manifest,
and I want you to plan it against
this database and give it a URI and
run it. And we actually
run it that way in
Kubernetes at times when we're in controlled environments
that, like, we can't deploy an operator because
we can't get cluster RBAC level permissions, and
so we can still run it. It's,
like, it's less automated at the end of
the day. You still get the benefits of
SchemaHero, but, like, it doesn't, you know like,
some of the ongoing like, the benefits of
an operator is you have that reconcile loop
that's running continuously in the cluster, and you
lose that. Yeah. I'm assuming for people that
aren't doing local development, I get Kubernetes. This
is the best way as well for them.
Like, If they're just doing Docker Compose to
run their their services, but they still wanna
manage and use SchemaHero
for the local dev environment, they could just
do the SchemaHero
plan, apply, you logic themselves.
Yeah. For sure.
Yeah. Exactly. And like you another use of
it, it's not built into the operator, is
we have a
a generate command,
which you can use, like, against an existing
database. And you can just say, you know,
like, one of the things that we've done
is SchemaHero is we've said, oh, here's a
declarative
structure. There are Kubernetes manifests, and this defines
the table. Well, if you have an existing
database, that can be a little bit tricky
to migrate over if you have, you know,
hundreds of tables and it's complex. And so
SchemaHero generate will actually, like, connect to the
database, describe the schema, and then spit it
all out for you so you have a
starting point, you can actually migrate to SchemaHero.
Oh, nice. We'll definitely have to try that
then before we finish. Is that is that
part of our tutorial?
It's not, but, like, well, let's try it.
Alright. Do wanna do that first or do
you wanna go stick to this tutorial first
and and Let's go through this tutorial here.
Alright. Okay. Wise wise decision.
So we've done we have screen available locally.
We have that available inside our cluster, and
now we need to connect our database.
So what databases does SchemaHero support?
So
we support
Postgres,
MySQL,
Cassandra, CockroachDB,
and
SQLite. And I think we're working on adding
support for
Yugabyte right now.
The goal is, like, you know,
common databases, and we wanna continue to expand
that.
Cool. Awesome.
So I don't know. If you already have
Postgres running,
David, like, we might wanna skip some of
these parts here and
Yeah. So I actually have a port forward
to both Postgres and MariaDB running another terminal
on my machine.
So
No. Great.
Oh, this is the app I'm using. I
didn't realize that this was in the documentation,
this beekeeper app. So that's obviously quite a
a good choice. I picked it for a
completely silly reasons. I thought it looked nice,
and it's the only reason when I search
for Postgres clients, I picked beekeeper. But I'm
glad that that this has validated something for
me now. So I'm gonna have That's actually,
that's why we picked it and put it
in the docs too because it just looks
better than most of the other ones.
Yeah. I I actually I was playing, like,
those Versus Code plugins now where you can
just, like, open empty text files and write
SQL and then say execute and stuff, but
I felt that was a bit a bit
hardcore for this stream. I like these visual
things.
Okay. Sorry. Digress in there. I'm gonna copy
our manifest here, which is going to
create a database
on our database.
I guess we should just have a code
session too. Right?
Yeah. We're gonna erase some YAML.
Love me some YAML.
I've lost my mouse. There we go.
Alright. So database1.YAML.
So pretty standard Kubernetes looking manifest here.
It's
okay. So the URI is coming from a
secret of a key. I mean, can I
hard put that?
Yeah. You can. If we look at the
the docs, we can see
exactly how.
So let's let's head over to the the
documentation tab instead of the tutorial tab.
I was hoping for a duplicate action there,
but I'll just do that. There we go.
Docs.
Then connecting data.
Actually, that's another example.
There you go. The reference for all fields.
There we go. So Alright. Value.
Okay. Yeah.
Obviously, in production,
like, don't mind. It's just hard to Yeah.
It's just because I I have no idea
about the config map. So secrets available on
this cluster. This was a civil marketplace installs
the database. I took no ownership of it
whatsoever. So I'm just going to provide
the service name, which is going to be
old square sql.
Default.
Svc.
Cluster.
Local.
And I'll assume
we're gonna just put the port on on
that. I think we need I think it
needs to be like a there's like a
PostgresQL.
Yeah. Exactly.
And
then you can throw, like,
if don't need a username and a password,
do you need the username and password to
connect? How is it deployed? Yeah. We we
will need a username and password. So I
just oh, yeah. I'll just put them in
the URI then. So
Sorry. Sorry. It's not a publicly available Postgres
No. One hopes.
Yeah. Cluster IP. Safe. What could go wrong?
Yeah. Perfect. Okay. So I need to describe
my postgres config map, which has all of
my stuff.
I wanted get
DB
password.
User.
This is terrible as secure.
Some random Don't don't judge me too much.
That that may be enough. I don't think
we need to put the DB name in
or anything because we're creating a database. So
I think what we have here should be
enough for it to work.
The database already exists in in it. So
one thing SchemaHero today doesn't do is create
the database for you. It assumes that you've
provisioned a date. We have a feature request
on on that, but, like, you have to
yeah.
Alright. Okay. So
I think the database just goes on the
end.
Yeah.
That is part of this
blurb.
Postgres DB.
Alright.
So it's impressive that you can write a
Postgres connection URI off the top of your
head. That's
Well, it's not worked you had. It's not
worked yet. Right?
Fair enough.
Alright. Are we feeling confident?
Let's do it.
Or Oh, we gotta change the name and
the namespace up there. You probably wanna name
it something not AirlineDB.
I don't know. But you can. Whatever you
want.
Rawkode
five.
Why not? Alright. Let's try again.
Okay. So I'm assuming I can just run
get databases.
Yeah. Exactly.
I'm assuming if I run describe, we make
some events or
We should, yeah.
And
no events there. But if we look at
like if you want to do like a
get pods,
what this actually did is created one controller
pod, like the Rawkode Live controller zero.
Nice.
And that's the one that's going be managing
this database. And
I know one of the things that's always
tricky is debugging some of these systems. And
so this is, like, where to go to
watch logs. You know, it'll spit out, like,
the the schema and, like, any kind of
challenges or problems and and and errors it
runs into here.
Okay.
I mean, I'm assuming there's no error message,
so the connection probably
worked?
I think so. Yeah. This is this looks
good. This is a positive result.
At least a better error tutorial.
I'm assuming we wanna start creating some tables
next. So That's good.
So to do a validate, we try and
get databases.
Yeah. Cool.
Alright. Let's create our first table.
Again,
SQL flashbacks there.
Yeah.
I haven't written any SQL in so long.
I've gotta say.
Good. You shouldn't have to. It gets gone.
Alright. So we could just modify oh, no.
We're creating a new object. So we've got
a table there. Got it.
Let's just keep it in the same file.
Keep it simple for now. So k. We'll
call I can call this table, I'm assuming.
Oh, this is the manifest name. Right? So
Yeah.
Let's
call that
project.
I'll just use my own namespace.
It's going to the database that I just
created, which I called Rawkode Live.
And the name like, if I admit this,
does it use the manifest name or no.
It doesn't. That's a good idea.
Yeah.
Like, we we have them as separate fields
just so you know. Like, we we like
underscores and table names, and Kubernetes doesn't like
underscores and manifest names. And so we ended
up, like, having some weirdness, and that's why
they're two fields. But, like, you know, I
like the idea.
Okay. So we're gonna have a primary key.
I'll just keep the airport schema just now.
I mean, we can modify it and play
with it and see what happens. But for
right now, I think this is enough to
test that we're
we're on something that may be working.
Great. You happy with that? That looks good.
Yeah. And we can connect already to beekeeper
and see the the schema and stuff like
that. Right? Yeah. We should be able to.
So I'm gonna apply that.
Get databases
and tables.
Looks good.
I don't know what I'm looking for, but
I think it looks good. I'm gonna Looks
good. Describe. We've got the schema.
So one thing you can do here is
actually use the
kubectl
plugin that we have there, and you can
do kubectl
SchemaHero
get tables or get migrations.
Well, I think we're gonna dig into, like,
the migrations part of it here. So
Okay.
So Penta and Zeta, that sounds good?
Yeah.
Well, it didn't
there's no migration, which is a little bit
weird.
I would have expected there to be a
migration that it, like, needed to deploy this
table. It may either still be running or
some other problem. Like
Oh, now we gotta fail to connect.
So
my confidence with my Postgres
URI.
Looks like fill the split host port. Oh,
there's like a slash missing, I think, it
looks like. I look at username, password, and
then a URI just shows right up there.
Oh, yeah. Silly,
silly, silly.
Be an at. Right? Yeah. Exactly. There you
go. An at sign's better.
Alright. Let's yeah. Let's just keep those logs
coming, actually.
We may
we may have to delete that pod and
let the
let the controller I don't know if that
pod's gonna automatically reconcile. That may be a
bug.
So if we run get migrations
right. Okay. Let's delete the pod. Let's
Yeah.
This is what reconciled loop is supposed to
do though for you. Right? Exactly. We'll let
that go away. We'll let it come back
and that'll be fixed.
Alright. Let's get our logs again.
No errors is good.
No errors is good. So with tables
migrations
planned.
Oh, we have a migration. Hey. Yeah. So
yeah.
If you actually run this with kubectl SchemaHero
get migrations,
we we spit the output a little bit
differently.
So we'll kind of
like, they're both valid. You see the same
names. Like, I think that we need to
change the way that we're doing this a
little bit in the project.
No. I can't do that. Okay. No. I
don't think we did that. So
Okay. So we've got one pending migration.
We've got a migration that
has been planned for fifty seconds. So what's
happening here? Can you fill me in? Yeah.
So you do it it fifty seconds ago,
it saw that there was, you know, a
table YAML that was deployed,
and it realized that there's something like, it
doesn't match the actual running schema in your
database, which I think is your current schema
has nothing in it. And this is a
plan to create a table. So it generated
the necessary DDL, like the
SQL statements that were going to be either
create table or alter table or whatever. And
it stores them in this migration CRD.
And then,
like, by default, SchemaHero
expects that there's some workflow here where you
can actually decide, I want to look at
this so you could control
SchemaHero describe migration and pass that ID in.
And it gives you the ability to, like,
check it and say, yeah, that's actually the
SQL that I want. You can turn that
off and let it auto deploy.
You can see the generated DDL statement there
is create table projects.
Alright.
So it's it's already given me the command.
So I can do approve
migration
and
drop the ID in. And that's gonna execute
the migration
and look at the table. Okay. What what
is the recalculate
there? Does that just tell to go build
that again?
Yeah. So we in that migration, we we
store
that create table statement. That way, we're, like
we calculated it one time, and now we
store it.
So recalculate
will basically erase it's supposed to erase that
and tell it, like, go go look at
the database again and see if that's still
the same command or what you need to
do. Okay. So if I was modifying it
manually at that point in time, I might
wanna ask it to go back and recalculate.
Exactly. What happens if I reject it?
Nothing other than it puts a timestamp that
says you rejected it at this time. Like,
that's all it does right now. Alright. Okay.
Let's not reject it. Let's approve
and run.
No. We wanted to to table. Right?
Yeah. Either get migrations or get tables. So
there's zero pending now.
Okay. Executed, approved,
no rejection.
Is this where we open beekeeper and Yeah.
Let's do it. Let's make let's make sure
the table actually like like, SchemaHero did what
it's supposed to do here.
Alright.
We got our projects.
Cool. No data in that button.
Yeah. How to how to add data?
I've not gone that far with BitKeeper yet.
View data. Oh, views view yeah. Or view
structure maybe too. You can actually yeah.
I I don't know how to
I should start playing with the the oh,
there we go. Alright. Code.
I'm in Glasgow.
There we go. We have our first airport.
Cool. Great. I just wanted to put in,
like, one row so that we can maybe
migrate the data and we'll actually see that
that we don't lose that data. I think
that would
that's important. I think you
I'm not a beekeeper expert here either, but
I'm I I I suspect you gotta click
that apply button at the bottom there. Yeah.
That should be a bright color. Come on,
beekeeper. Yeah. There we go. And
select
star
from
that will complete too.
Sweet. Okay. There we go.
So we're confident that SchemaHero did this job.
That's pretty cool.
Back to this tutorial, are we I want
I think let's
like, the next step in the tutorial was
just, like, go modify the table. So, like,
if whatever let's let's let's go modify stuff.
Oh, yeah. So let's just wait. Okay. So
Yeah. Everything happens,
and our
database CRD and our table most of our
table's c d
but we have this database for the custom
resource.
So
let's
because this is declarative, I can just do
whatever I want. Right? Within reason. Yeah.
With Yeah.
Alright. So I've decided this is going multilingual.
We'll do English name.
Now what I'm curious about this specific
scenario is
there's nothing really to tie this to being
formally
named. So the SchemaHero
look at the previous schema and understand that
this is a rename because the type is
the same? Does it think it's a new
column and drop the old column?
Or do I have to add anything to
tie this to what was the column formerly
known as name? Like
Yeah.
Yeah. You you jump to the the hard
the hard declarative scheme migration problems here.
It's it's unfortunately the second right now where
it's going to see this as the table
no longer has a column named name, and
now it has a column named English name.
So the
I I I think that SchemaHero is gonna
calculate this as drop column and add column,
you're gonna lose that one piece of data.
There's a issue in the repo to say,
like, you know,
prior names are for like, exactly where you
went with that last option, like like, be
able to list for for former names and
then be able to rename columns. But today,
it's not in the in the product yet.
Okay. So there it doesn't rename. So we
would just always leave the column names as
is really and work with with new columns.
So Yeah. We we can add columns. We
can modify column types, constraints, keys, you know,
things like that for sure, but, like or
indexes,
but not not renaming columns yet.
Okay. Cool.
Let's
add
one more column then.
Got a preference?
Let's go. What what what what else does
airports have? Like,
number of runways or something like that. Yeah.
There we go.
Yeah. Runways up. That'll do. Type.
And is
that number n is there any abstractions? Am
I working directly with the Postgres types here?
Just Postgres types here. So, like, int, you
know, big int or yeah. Whatever, like, whatever
Postgres types are. Okay.
And can I set, like, a default value
or anything like this?
Yeah. You can. We may have to look
at the docs off the top of my
head on that one, but, like, you you
can set a default value. Yeah. We've got
the reference open here. Right? So if we
click on
table
okay. So we could do foreign keys.
We've got our indices,
columns.
We can set a not null.
I I don't even know if Postgres does
have default values, to be fair. I was
just thinking.
No. We do that in we use that
in my SQL quite a bit.
I'm
curious if we we
question.
Okay. So we got
let's just do a not null.
Alright.
So that's constraints
not null on the column. That we got
it here.
This will be a good one because it's
gonna show you that it like, you already
have a piece of data, you already have
one row in there and, you know, adding
a new column with a not null and
not a default, like, post credits is not
gonna, you know, it's not gonna be happy
with that that alter table statement. Right?
Yeah.
Good point. I hadn't thought of that, but
that's cool. So let's break it.
Let's break it.
Let's do an apply.
And then if I run SchemaHero, get migrations.
We've got a new planned one and I
can describe
the ID.
So this was to do author table projects,
add column runways, integer, not null.
Kinda what I expect.
So do we approve this?
Let's approve it.
I'm assuming that's never gonna be executed because
of
the constraint. Is that what's happening?
I it
right. It never successfully executes. And so I
think if you look at the logs of
that controller pod again, you'll see the actual
error here.
Yeah. Okay.
Well, it's it's got no values because this
doesn't exist. So I think we do
so I was gonna say, think we I
think we do support the default field here
as a as a
string. So, like, if you if you wanna
take this one step farther, let's actually go
and and add default
at the same YAML level as type.
So the reference doesn't have it, but my
autocomplete, which is creating against the cluster, does
pick it up. Interesting.
I think you have to I think it's
a string type, and then we'll cast it
in, like, Zins. Yeah.
What else we got? Attributes.
What's that? Oh, okay. We thought it well,
that would be silly, but, yeah, we could
cool.
Let's try that again. So we approved that
migration,
and now we're gonna generate a new migration.
Is that going like, what's the workflow here?
Do I have to now reject the old
one
in order for that to work?
When it's the same table,
what SchemaHero is going to do is it
it's going to it doesn't allow you to
have these, like, stair stepped migrations that are
in flight. So it's going to say, like,
you have a migration for this table. Now
when you deploy this new YAML, it's gonna
calculate a new migration for this table, so
it'll replace the one that's sitting there failing
right now.
Will it take away the approved state and
then it's reapproved?
It will. Yeah. It'll be just back to,
like, two migrations, one's unapproved.
Alright. That sounds good to me. There we
go. Planned, not approved.
Oh, no. That's the third one.
It may be a recent change that we
keep it there, so you for for for
for audit purposes. But yeah.
Alright. So alter table projects at columnar is
not l d four zero.
As you can see that this one calculated
that against the current state of the database,
not against the current state plus the pending
migration here. Right?
Yeah. It wasn't altering
the column. It was adding it's still adding
a new column.
Okay. Let's approve this one then and
then get
executed and approved.
Sweet.
So if we go to beekeeper
and we run this query, yeah, we get
runway zero. Cool. That worked.
Hey.
It's good when things work. Right?
Yes. Let's refresh.
Okay.
I'm gonna just keep trying to break stuff.
Are are you comfortable with that? Let's let's
do it. Alright. I'm gonna modify the schema
myself.
So if I can work out how to
do that. In fact, I'm I'm gonna cheat.
Where was the alter statement?
So I don't know how to add columns
with beekeeper, but we do have this query
window, so I'm just gonna use it.
So let's add a column called
never,
like so.
Now
in my head, what I expect to happen
here is for SchemaHero to detect this
and per generate a new migration to remove
it.
Is that what you think is gonna happen?
Very, very, very close. That's what should happen.
The only thing you have to do today
is
you like, SchemaHero
has that table as in sync, we don't
continuously reconcile and put a load on the
database querying it. Like, there's a a thing
that we we wanna figure out how to,
like, do that drift detection in large databases
without, like, overloading the database, hitting the schema
up constantly.
So today, there's you could either deploy any
other change to the table, or if you
delete, like, delete table dash all
then just redeploy that table, exactly what you
said will happen. It just there's no trigger
in the reconcile loop to tell it to
go recalculate that right now.
Okay.
So our best way forward would be just
to
modify
as soon as all airports have at least
one runway.
Sure. It's not an airport otherwise. Or yeah.
Apply.
Okay. So, yeah, I I wanna make sure
I understand. So SchemaHero does the reconciliation,
but if it believes your database doesn't sync,
it doesn't wanna add any the burden of
extra load querying on that. So
Yeah.
One thing that we do, and we can
dig into this a little bit later, is
we
use GitOps inside our production environment that's constantly
sinking YAML into the cluster. So when we
run into this problem, we'll just delete
a table YAML. SchemaHero, by the way, just
like it won't
it's designed to be relatively safe. If you
delete this table YAML, it's not going to
go drop the table from the database. It's
going to leave it there and think that's
now an unmanaged table. There's a is deleted
field that you can set in the YAML,
which will actually tell SchemaHero, I want you
to actively go delete this table. So one
trick that we do to kind of poke
SchemaHero when we need to is just delete
the table YAML, let Flux redeploy it, and
then it recalculates
it.
Okay.
Cool.
Let's
approve
this one
and
refresh here impatiently.
Let's do it. Don't have don't have to
be very impatient. Okay. Perfect. Yeah.
That that it's working. It's doing everything that
I kinda want it to do. I'm pretty
happy with that.
Now I'm gonna do the thing that you
said,
which is
is it here?
Yeah.
And that's just a billion. So as this
manifest is deleted, it will delete the table?
Exactly. Yeah. So you can probably get rid
I mean, you can obviously, you can leave
the rest of the data there too, but
it's not gonna be that important.
Alright. Okay. I understand you. So when I
apply this, it will delete the table. It's
not an indicator that if the manifest disappears
to delete. Okay. That makes sense. Yeah. Exactly.
Which we we we errored on a, like,
really, like, you know, side of caution that,
like, you know, you you need to
you need to say very declaratively,
I want this table deleted. Not like, the
absence of a YAML means we should delete
this table. That felt a little too risky
for what we wanted to do with her
an early project.
Yeah. Working with databases, you've got you've I
guess you've always got the error in the
state of caution. Right? The last thing you
want is people complaining that
things disappeared.
Let's try.
I'm going have to approve the migration route.
Yeah.
So there is an
immediate deploy flag on the database that you
can set.
And then when you when that when you
have that set, SchemaHero doesn't wait for you
to immediately for you to approve them. It
just automatically moves them into the the approved
phase.
Okay. Let's approve this one first, and then
let's try that.
Right.
So
I've lost the number. There we go.
Beekeeper.
Alright. Definitely gone. Okay.
I've now realized that that was a terrible,
terrible mistake. Okay.
So
where do I set the we don't need
approval thing? Is that on the database or
on the table?
It's on the database.
I believe it's right under your autocomplete will
help you. I believe it's right underneath Postgres.
Should be immediate deploy.
No. Maybe up under connection.
Or we may need to look at docs.
Oh,
database. Right? So let's pop over here.
Oh, yeah. Media us on the spec. Okay.
Yeah. This is what's the enable shell command?
So if, you know, you have a database
SchemaHero can talk to your database, obviously.
Interestingly,
to your point, you have this port forward
setup
in order to connect through
to the cluster IP
service.
The shell command basically will allow you to
kubectl SchemaHero shell database name, and that'll create
a it'll create a pod running PostgresQL
and exec you into that to connect to
the local database so that you can actually
get into a database that you don't have
a direct route to. Oh, nice.
I'm
gonna try that too.
Alright.
On spec. I don't know why we're not
getting the autocomplete.
I don't know. I
think we were we never went high enough
on it.
I I'm I'm sure I did. I'm gonna
rewatch this later and be like
I'm I'm determined to prove Versus code wrong.
Okay.
I'm sorry Versus code. It was me.
Okay. So we're this is gonna get us
our shell command under immediate deploy so we
can start adding columns, and we should just
see that instance. So I'm gonna reapply.
Do I need to
restart the controller for that change?
It's a great question.
I'm I'm wondering that myself right now. So
let's see if it deletes if it does
it by itself.
It should do it by itself. The right
the right behavior of SchemaHero would be to
do it by itself. Yeah. There we go.
Oh, it did. Great. Yes. We have the
thing.
Okay. So When you look at migrations, you'll
still see, by the way, that, like, it
still goes through the same phase.
You know? It's just that it auto approves
it for you because we we
you still have an audit log of exactly
when it was approved and and and executed.
Alright. Well, let's add
funny joke. I don't know.
Too much pressure,
Varcher.
Okay.
So
play
beekeeper.
Funny joke. Okay.
That's pretty cool to see that instantaneous
kind of reconciliation
when I when I make the changes here.
Yeah.
I guess that's that's confidence mode. Right?
Exactly. We you know you know, completely
transparently,
we we have that enabled
for pre prod environments, for QA test environments,
and dev environments, but we actually still don't
do that for our our own production environment.
We still have a thing where we're like,
some you know, a human should not write
the SQL statement, but, like, look at it
and decide it's okay to run.
Is this something where there's, you know or
do you see tooling or if that's eventually
coming where when the migration gets created, you
know, it's posted to Slack, if someone can
just approve it. I don't know if I'd
want Slack hiccups quite there, but at least
a notification to say this this pending migration,
this is what it looks like. And
is that tooling that you're using yourselves, or
is it very much just keep control all
the time?
Yeah.
Right now, we're still doing keep control all
the time. Like that, like, finding that right
workflow.
So it's like, is it is it chat
ops? Is it, like, in Slack? Is it,
like, you know, how do you do it?
It's it's a it's a great question, actually.
Like, we're
like, I don't think, like, running kubectl approved
migration is the right path, honestly. Like, it's
like it gives you the workflow and the
check that you need in place, but, like,
they're honestly, like like, it's like
you know, working with large enterprises, they have,
like, change management systems and, like, you should
have, like, an audited event of, like, who
approved that thing
into large migrations be you know, because, like,
it can have negative effects, and you just
wanna know who's who's looking you wanna make
sure some human is looking at them really
at the end of the day.
Okay.
Let's do one more thing, and then we'll
move over to your
your demo. Does that sound good? Sounds great.
I'm gonna do a delete
on this because I wanna do it without
the operator.
Alright.
So
oh, it's in a namespace. Right? So SchemaHero.
Yeah. I'm assuming this is the deployment. No.
No. It was s s t s. Right?
So it was named that way.
S t s SchemaHero.
So we now have no more operator or
controller running for that. And you said Right.
So I I I wanna think about the
local dev thing.
When I meet teams and people, they're not
always deploying to Kubernetes.
They are for production, but when it comes
to dev, they're still using
local services or Docker Compose.
It's one of tooling that. So I'm curious
if I have my application. I've got this
op directory with the SchemaHero.
I've got the the exact same YAML here
that I've shipped to prod. What's my process
to get that working
with just the SchemaHero command?
Yeah.
So
there's, like, one page in the docs that
show it.
Like, we'll we'll let's go through it and
we'll figure it out here. I don't like,
the the the CLI command syntax exactly off
the top of my head. Under documentation,
under advanced,
there's a page called operatorless mode is what
we call it right now.
And
this starts to show you how you can
like,
this shows it running as a job in
Kubernetes, which is probably, you know, like, looking
at this now thinking that's probably not the
right syntax to give you, like, the operator
list mode in because we we designed this
really being like, I wanna run this in
Kubernetes, but I don't have cluster admin permissions.
But you can actually see that it's running,
you know, the job. You know, we may
have to, like, reverse engineer this a little
bit to say, like, okay. It's running SchemaHero
plan,
and then it's passing in a couple of
args to it. You know? Yeah. I'm sure
we could work with that. So Yeah.
K. Email. Let's
try that plan first.
This will take the YAML as
yeah, spec file and spec type. Right? So
let's try spec file.
And you don't have to deploy a database
type here. Like
because what you can do is just pass
in
driver
driver and URI
right on the CLI. So you can pass
in driver equals Postgres
and then URI equals that connection string. And
then just the plan to the YAML, and
it'll it should it should plan it for
you. Oh, so it's not parsing the custom
resources on the YAML to pull out the
database information and the table. It's
Yeah. It parses the custom resource in the
table, but you you basically you you deconstruct
the database part and give it as CLI
flags at this point.
Alright.
At URA.
Let's just copy that.
Back
fail.
Yeah.
So a couple things I think are are
causing the problem. One is, like, your machine,
don't think can access like, local host five
four three two is gonna be a problem
here. Oh, no. Do you still have the
port forward open so it actually could probably
do that? Yep. They're still running because that's
what Beekeeper's using right now. Let's
drop the table, like, because it might just
be that there's no differences detected or something
like that. Oh, yeah. I had to delete
the alright. Okay.
Drop
table.
Done.
There's like a out
pram. I maybe
I should've written docs, shouldn't I?
Yeah. That's just
Alright. So alright. It takes environment variables. Okay.
So
this seems to be potentially a directory,
and there's a schema here which will create
so I was trying I was gonna create
migration. It was okay. So
I think we're close.
Yeah.
What am I missing?
So I think there's maybe looking for a
directory.
So I'm gonna do spec.
I'll equals dot
maybe out migrations.
No. Not quite.
I still got my database file. Yeah. Okay.
We're close. Oh, you know, let's let's
like,
I'm kind of I'm kinda guessing a little
bit here where we're like but let's can
we comment out or do like, let's make
that database one YAML only have table specs
and not a database spec in it.
Alright. Okay. Yeah.
Okay. So migration.
That seems promising.
Yeah.
Alright. So it's trying to unmarshal something and
failing. So that's I think
It did work. Oh, because dot contained other
files. Yeah. Yeah.
I
think I'm confusing it. So let's do r
equals
migration.
You should also I think spec file can
take a directory or a file. Like, you
can I think that we can support both
there?
There's just a dot at the end of
it. Oh.
Alright.
Oh, that's a fail.
Oh, but we did get the migration. Okay.
So
based on that,
I'm assuming
I could plan all the way back here.
Apply.
Yeah.
And this is gonna take
Slash d d or dash dash d d
l is the, I guess, the parameter name
here. D l equals
migration.
Oh, hey.
There. We did it.
Well, and you never wrote SQL.
Okay. That's cool. So,
yeah, we can without Kubernetes local development environments,
we can point it to a file or
directory containing our table definitions. So we'd probably
keep our databases separately.
But, yeah, my my my
local repository for my application code is never
gonna contain that database CID. I mean, that's
gonna be always come from platform and and
ops team.
And so the table one's just living there.
Actually, it probably makes a better sense.
And then we can do the plan and
apply. We get the migrations,
and it worked.
Cool. I'm I'm I'm happy with that. Great.
We're gonna move to your demo now. We
have a question from Rio in the chat,
which I'll throw over to you.
So Rio asks, is there a way to
set the name of the migration beforehand?
This could enable CI systems to block deployments
of specific software until SchemaHero shows a migration
has been executed.
It's a it's a good question.
So today,
like, those those IDs that were, like, the
name of the migrations,
they're actually deterministically
calculated by the generated SQL statement that is
being created.
And one of the benefits of that is
if you have to recalculate them or whatever,
the ID won't change. You end up with
a history.
Every time I deploy the same migration from
the same state, I get this ID. So
today, like, no. There's that's unfortunately, that's not
possible.
And it's an interesting thing to to to
think about, but today, we we they're all
they're all calculated
deterministically.
I guess you could have it in a
container, though, that looked up all migrations
and made sure that we're all up to
date before deploying software. I I mean, if
that was part of your workflow.
But, yeah, maybe something Yeah.
Yeah. It's actually
we have a monorepo that has the database
migrations and
our code in it. And so when
we deploy a change that involves code changes
and a schema change, it becomes a little
bit
tricky. And you have to be careful
if we don't have immediate deploy to true
because if that gets deployed all the way,
you might have code that expects a column
to exist and you haven't approved that migration
yet.
We,
like,
have decided to handle this by saying,
you know, don't write code that is hard
dependent on that column to be there. Like,
you can handle that by writing code a
little bit differently. That's not like, we don't
want to tell you to change the way
you write code. So that's that's a overall
problem if you're handling, you know, monorepo that
handles code and migrations, though. Like, there's a
it's a challenge. Yeah. Definitely. Alright.
Do you wanna share your screen, and we'll
we'll take a look at what you got,
Ashul?
Sure. I'll I'll share here. Alright. So
great. So
what I have
is
alright. So I have a
Kubernetes cluster just running on DigitalOcean and a
managed separate out of the cluster MySQL server
right here.
And then MySQL server is only available inside
the cluster. It's set up similar to the
cluster IP, obviously, but it's like a VPC
firewall rule that's making it so it's not
publicly accessible
because that's how people run production systems, hopefully.
And also in case I accidentally show a
password here on the screen, I'm not super
worried.
And, like, I did a little bit more
prep on this one, and I have Flux
running.
So I have Flux running in a GitOps
deployed pipeline. So I can just write code,
commit it, GitHub actions runs, and then it
gets automatically deployed.
And the thing that I wanted to show
was a couple of things here.
We've been playing around a lot lately
with a new version of SchemaHero.
Oops. Sorry about that.
And so this is like the alpha version
of 13,
which is currently in progress. We hope to
ship this in mid February.
And there's a really cool feature in it,
and my goal was to show that. So
I'm I'm gonna basically go through the same
same demo. We'll go pretty quickly.
We're gonna install the 13
operator
to this cluster,
and
that's going to spin up the operator.
Here I have a
semi,
potentially
typical
repo that has a CI pipeline, more matches
like how you actually would run stuff in
production.
This pipeline is lit I mean, in order
to make the CI process really quick for
this, I don't have code in it. It's
literally just customize
running
a bunch of, like, manifests.
And I have sealed secrets installed so that
I can actually deploy secrets through a GitOps
pipeline.
Here, I have a database YAML.
And the database YAML, I have the same
commands that we just looked at, immediate deploy
and enable shell command, and this deploy seed
data set to true, which is one of
the cool new features of 13 that I
wanted to show off.
In
my production overlay for customize and sorry. I'm
throwing a lot here, like, around GitOps and
Flux and customize and everything. Like, I think
that, you know, just trying to, like, demo
a more, like, you know, realistic end production
environment.
So
I have a sealed secret that contains my
connection string for MySQL.
Yep.
The sealed secret's Helm repository.
And so
what I'm gonna do is deploy all of
this. I have a schemas,
and the schema has the same, you know,
basic table.
I'm
actually gonna comment that part out for now.
And so this is the same basic table
here. It's called airport this time, but it
has the code and the airport name.
And the customization here only has the airport
YAML.
So
really quickly I need to make the window
smaller so I can see the terminal prompt.
So if I look at, like, customize build,
you know, customize overlays production,
and we look at see what that actually
is creating,
you know, we just have a sealed secret
here. We have our database object, which we're
familiar with. We just went through it.
And
then
I don't have a table
because
I probably forgot to save a file somewhere
or something like that.
Let's try that one more time.
I have a table in here.
So
base database
customization.
Oh, yeah. Here. I need to include the
schemas. Sorry.
Alright. So here. Now I have this airline
DB table or the airport table being deployed.
So
So we'll just push that to GitHub.
This is the repo that I pushed it
to.
And a GitHub action is gonna run, which
is going to basically go,
you know, run unit tests, run all the
tests that normally run-in CI. For this one,
it's it's really quick. It takes about thirty
to forty seconds to run all the way
through CI.
And then we'll render out that customization YAML
and put it into a a a separate
repo that Flux is watching.
And wait for all that works, so I
can, like, you know, kubectl get
tables,
and I don't have anything. There's nothing deployed.
So we'll have flux do, like, a a
reconciliation
while this continues to run. It's red, but
I don't think that it's actually an error.
This is just what happens.
This should run pretty quickly, customize build, and
then upload all the rendered out YAML.
Where does it upload the render other another
repository?
Yeah. So we it's right now, it's going
to this other repository that I just created
called GitOps demo,
and it's gonna deploy it all right now.
You see it here. It just deployed this,
and so 10 ago.
So Flux is gonna watch this and pick
that up. So we'll try to push Flux
along and not have it set idle.
If I look at tables, it's there. I
can run the same commands that we were
just looking at, SchemaHero,
get migrations,
and this is approved. It's there. So this
is because we have immediately immediate deploy set
to true.
The thing that I wanna show here is
a couple of things. So kubectl schema hero
get databases.
Our database is named AirlineDB.
So I can run kubectl schema hero
shell
that
and that's gonna run on my SQL pod
on that cluster and give me a connection
and do it. That's cool. Now yeah.
So I can show tables.
I have the airport table. Select star from
airport. And sorry. I don't have beekeeper setup
with port forward here, so this is a
little bit harder.
The table's empty. So coming back here to
the part that I wanted to show,
which is the part that we're excited about,
is we added the seed data
where I added a couple airport codes. Right?
Like, I have two two rows in the
database, JFK and
LAX.
I'm gonna go ahead and add that.
We'll push that up to the repo.
We wait another minute while while this action
runs.
And
what it should do
is
the end result will be that the the
manifest with the seed data will end up
over here in our GitOps
repo.
One thing to note while the CI runs
is
we set this, like, that you have to
opt into it for seed data because one
of the things we ran into, we'd like,
we we deployed it. We were using it
in our dev environments to do things like,
you know, deploy features and entitlements or feature
toggles entitlements and a little bit of, like,
you know, fixture data that you need to
run tests. And it was, like, super
useful. And then right when we started to
think, okay. Let's merge this in and push
it out to production, we were like, wait.
We don't want all this data in production
either. So we ended up having to, like,
make that something that you can opt into
and out of at the database level for
now.
So this should
finish this
CI here in a second.
So why if you opted for this kind
of two step GitOps deployment where you push
to another repository rather than having Flux just
apply the the YAML directly?
Yeah. It's a great question.
It it match like, I think it's let's
call it muscle memory of the way that
we've been using Flux. We we adopted Flux
with Flux one point o when it didn't
have support for customize built into it. And
so we ended up having to do these,
like, kind of CI processes to do it.
And like this
like, was easy for me to set up
in order to do it. Like, no other
reason than that.
Good. That's a good enough reason. Sorry.
So the seed data is now here.
And if we come back here and we
select star from airport,
there's two two rows of data in the
database now. So it's not just Schema. We're
starting to get into
into
the actual data.
But can you describe that migration? Is that
just gonna be in the search statement?
It it it well, almost. Almost. Let me
get migrations.
It is in search statements,
but I think it's important to point out
here that here. Let me
I've been talking, so I don't know how
you do it.
Subscribe migration.
So it is just insert statements.
But for MySQL, we do the on duplicate
key update.
And for Postgres, it'll say, like, insert ignore
statements
because,
like, we know they're gonna be regenerated all
the time.
And the idea is,
you know,
primary key in this table is the code
column. So as long as the one of
the primary keys is included in the seed
data, which, like, likely is going to be
anyway or else it's not gonna be a
very valid piece of data,
this works. That allows me to
delete that row. And then the next time
it's, like, drift detection, it'll put that seed
data back, but it also makes sure that
it's not duplicated each time, if that makes
sense.
Yeah. Definitely. I think that's a really cool
feature for, again, that development workflow as well.
I've been able to do the plan and
apply and get data that is,
you know, crafted alongside the the schema itself.
Makes a lot of sense.
Yeah. Yeah. I think that's a really cool
feature.
I'm gonna stop sharing here. But, like, yeah,
the
no.
But, like, the
that's exactly what we use it for. You
know? Our our dev environments, we ended up
with you know, like most folks, we have,
you know, a table full of features. And,
like, you know, when we wanna roll them
out, like, everybody has to run migrations to
insert those features into their database for feature
toggles or, like, there's, you know,
generic
fixture data that we use for, you know,
different types of tests. And to make sure
that the tests are portable between environments, we
can actually just throw the the data into
the seed data and not put it into
production.
Yeah. I've got a a feature request for
you that you can bring for 14 now.
Is that instead you know, when I have
the seed data, I've been able to use
the faker library and say, like, this is
the first name. This is an address. This
is the second name. And Oh, that's good.
Generate 10 or 20 or a hundred or
a thousand of them. That would be a
really cool feature as well. That's cool. So
seed data would be less deterministic but more
just like like, let's just fill everybody's environment
up with it and, like, we're gonna find
some problems and Yeah. You know, if you
wanna do some property based testing or you
wanna do some load based testing and really
fill and hammer thing up a little bit,
it would be cool to be able to
have a seat there that is deterministic and
then populate it with maybe a whole bunch
of undeterministic stuff. So and determine I like
it. I like
it. We may have to go add that
in. I like that that idea. Yeah. I
don't know if you're familiar with the Faker
project, but it's just this really cool library
for generating fake data with, like, types and
understands what it is. It's pretty cool. Yeah.
No. It's great. Love it. Alright. Well, that
was awesome. Thank you so much for kind
of working with us today and showing us
that that demo was cool to see the
other things great. That shell command was great.
That would have saved me a a whole
bunch of setup with beekeeper stuff, but well.
You know? Yeah. That's this this is why
we do these things. To show these features
to people so they see how they work.
We've got one question that popped on right
at the end there that'll pop up for
real.
So everything until now has been connection based.
How does it work with SQLite?
So
I can it basically works the same way.
Like, you you can write a SQLite URI
that just points to a file name, and
then that'll point to a SQLite file.
It's identical otherwise. David pointed out earlier, you
know, like, he asked about the type, whether
that's like an abstraction or just raw Postgres
types.
And you'll notice, like, in the database or
in the table schema,
there was a Postgres key. And in the
one that I did, there was a MySQL
key. So, like, the schema can change. We
don't try to, like, normalize and make sure
the schema is identical between them all. We
try to make them as similar as possible.
But, like, SQLite works, you just pass in
a, you know, a SQLite connection string.
Yeah. SQLite is something that I was interested
in. In fact, I I actually plan first
to do a bit of a demo there,
but I got carried away with the the
postcard stuff. So I think I'm I'm definitely
gonna be playing with SQLite sidecars with SchemaHeroes
and having some fun there. So I'll be
sure to get some tutorials or something onto
the channel. But
yeah. Awesome.
Alright. Any last words, Mark, before I let
you go back to your day?
No. I think, you know, you know, it's
a sandbox project. Like, if I if I
can, like, you know, like, we we been
in the sandbox for a year. I'd love
what we're really looking for is just, you
know, folks who, you know, find use cases
and, like, hit us up on the Kubernetes
Slack. There's a SchemaHero channel. Like, things where
it's working or not working, you know, we
wanna you know, we have a goal of
trying to get out of the sandbox and
move it to an incubating project sometime this
year. In order to do that, we need
to have demonstrated,
you know, use cases, and we we know
it's out there. Use People are using it.
You know, love to, anything that we can
do to help unblock or, you know, feature
requests or
anything like this, just we'd love to talk.
Awesome. Alright, everyone. Get involved if you like
what you've seen. Sure Mark will be happy
to answer questions on GitHub issues, Twitter,
anywhere else that you're participating. Is there a
Slack for for this? Yeah. It's in the
Kubernetes Slack. Yep. Alright. Okay. So check out
the channel on the Kubernetes Slack. Alright. Well,
thank you again, Mark. It was really good
fun. I enjoyed that. I'm looking forward to
playing with SchemaHero a little bit more. So
thank you for your time today, and I'll
speak to you again soon.
Thank you.